ABCs of AI X is for XG boost an open
source Library used for machine learning
tasks it's an ensemble learning method a
machine learning approach that combines
multiple models to improve performance
the models are fitted to the same data
and their predictions are combined to
achieve better performance than any
individual model this means that XG
boost builds multiple models each
slightly improving on the previous one
until it reaches a desired level of
accuracy XG boost is designed to be
efficient and can handle large data sets
has a user-friendly interface and
several built-in features that make it
easy to use has consistently won machine
learning competitions demonstrating its
ability to achieve high accuracy on a
variety of tasks and is an open source
Library which means it's free to use and
modify so if you're looking for a
scalable flexible open source tool with
high accuracy and an active Community
take a look at XG boost stay tuned
there's only a couple letters left in